bonjour christian jacob bonjour on a
appris ce matin qu'emmanuel macron se
rendra lundi prochain en russie puis
mardi en ukraine que doit-il dire tout
d'abord la vladimir poutine lors de sa
rencontre d'abord que de temps perdu
vous rendez compte que le président de
la république française doit y avoir
plus de deux ans aux deux ans et demi
qu'il n'a pas rencontré le président
russe
emmanuel macron des totalement
inexistant sur la scène internationale
on va d'échec en échec tout simplement
parce qu'il n'a pas su entretenir ce
réseau relationnel avec les chefs d'état
et des chefs de gouvernement comme l'ont
fait tous ses prédécesseurs deux ans et
demi qu'il n'a pas vu le président russe
et ce qui se passe aujourd'hui aux
frontières de l'ukraine cette crise on
la voit monter l a pas hélas pas
commencé il ya 48 heures il ya trois
jours il ya quinze jours et aucune
initiative du président de la république
française alors que l'on sait bien un
coup de fil entre les deux hommes s'est
dit oui il ya eu pour la première fois
une vision il ya il ya quinze jours mais
donc il ya deux ans et demi qui ne
s'étaient pas parlés pas vu c'est un ccr
vraisemblance qui doit lui dire
aujourd'hui je pense que le président
russe s'était exprimé d'ailleurs à
plusieurs reprises sur le
sur le sujet le débat et sur les
frontières de l'otan sur l'intégration
de l'ukraine et il y à dd des forces
russes qui sont massés
aujourd'hui aux frontières du dombass
fin de d'une région de l'ukraine
les frontières de l'ukraine doivent être
respectés c'est une évidence est une
question de souveraineté mais par
ailleurs il doit y avoir une discussion
pour moi l'ukraine n'a rien à faire dans
l'otan il faut renoncer à ça mais je ne
vois pas aujourd'hui de la même façon
que quand on avait ouvert le débat sur
l'intégration de l'ukraine dans l'union
européenne
pour moi l'ukraine n'a rien à voir avec
l'union européenne et donc tout cela
plus les sanctions économiques
ridicule qui ad'ailleurs pénaliser
beaucoup les entreprises françaises les
sanctions économiques sur la sur la
russie on a coupé tout dialogue avec le
président russe et effectivement c'est
dur à reconstruire aujourd'hui le bien
évidemment que la souveraineté de
l'ukraine doit être préservée ça c'est
une évidence comme tout état mais il y
avait besoin d'un dialogue la france 3
ce matin vous dites il faut lever les
sanctions l'embargo dans la rue sans
mais je dis qu'on peut pas on peut pas
avoir un président de la république
française digne de ce nom qui soit deux
ans et demi sans rencontrer le président
russe alors qu'il ya une crise est en
train de monter on est très loin des
initiatives de nicolas sarkozy en 2008
sur la georgie où le contact a toujours
été maintenu avec le président et ce qui
n'empêche pas le oui enfin nord il ya eu
un une vision 3d c'est pas 2 ans et demi
qui se sont pas vus dernière fois
c'était à brégançon en 2010 9,2 de
mémoire si valérie pécresse arrive à
l'elysée tout ça ça va changer elle sera
régulièrement en contact 20 et de
renommer
un allié mais bien évidemment on doit
avoir ce contact des contacts directs va
dire qu'on est d'accord sur tout et et
chacun connaît le président poutine
s'agit pas on n'a pas vocation à être
inféodé aux uns aux autres mais
simplement la france un rôle privilégié
qu'elle a toujours su jouer et qui n'est
plus joué depuis qu emmanuel macron et
président de la république parce qu'il
est inexistant sur la scène
internationale il n'a pas su trouver sa
place il va de rodomontades rando dad
mais une fois que le verbe a été au
l'action est nul christian jacob dans
une interview au figaro marine le pen
explique eric zemmour est entouré de
personnages sulfureux et aussi de
quelques nazis est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec l idéal est sans doute
beaucoup plus experte que moi dans ce
domaine ces règlements de comptes au
sein de l'extrême droite entre entre
zemmour et et marine le pen voilà
échange de groupuscules au sein de
l'extrême droite nokia des nazis au tour
d'eric et j'en sais rien marine le pen
les connaît vraisemblablement puisque le
dit moi je je je n'ai pas la
connaissance de ce groupuscule mais mais
ce que l'on voit bien c'est que eric
zemmour est de plus en plus sulfureux
dans ses propos il ya effectivement
beaucoup
d'informations de personnes peu
fréquentables qui le rejoignent
maintenant l'experte c'est marine le pen
dans ce domaine vous les mettez tous les
deux dans le même panier si vous me
passez l'expression ou pas où vous dites
y en a un qui est plus extrême que
l'autre c'est l'extrême droite qui est
en train d'éclater comme ç'avait été le
cas mais c'est même famille joue ben oui
bien évidemment entre jean marie le pen
et bruno mégret on l'a déjà vu et
c'était d'ailleurs les mêmes groupes qui
avaient rejoint bruno mégret qui
rejoignent eric zemmour on revit la même
scène de l'éclatement de l'extrême
droite c'est étrange que vous disiez ça
et christian jacob parce qu'il ya encore
quelques semaines quand on vous
interroger sur eric zemmour vous disiez
il est pas raciste 2 il est pas
d'extrême droite là vous dites ou
l'envers ce jeudi qu'eric zemmour va de
dérapage en dérapage
et que effectivement entre les propos
qu'il tenait bon lorsqu'on l'a tous
connus et vous comme moi éditorialistes
journalistes dont il affirmé
des positions tranchées sur un certain
nombre de sujets mais on n'a jamais payé
par la justice voilà discours qu'il
avait tenu sur sur pétain qui protégeait
les juifs et puis bon sur les des
positions qui est qu'il prend maintenant
ces règlements de comptes au sein de
l'extrême droite et des différents
groupuscules qui ont toujours existé
dans l'extrême droite le rassemblement
national vous accusent les républicains
de dd eric zemmour a collecté ces
parrainages qu'est ce que vous répondez
à sauber lé absolument pas vous savez
j'ai eu l'occasion d'ailleurs de
m'exprimer très clairement sur sur sur
ce sujet le problème de financement des
za de rock recherche de parrainages des
autres c'est leur problème nous on a une
candidate et on est mobilisé autour de
notes de notre candidate et ensuite on
rentre pas dans ses coups de billard à
trois bandes ou à quatre bandes ça il ya
toujours des effets boomerang dans ce
genre de show les parrainages son public
christian jacob est leur apporte son
soutien son parrainage eric zemmour il
se passe quoi
à ma connaissance il y en a pas
énormément il y en aura à chaque
campagne vous savez moi je me suis
parfois retrouvés avec des des élus qui
me soutenaient qu'ils allaient parrainer
poutou qui allaient bon je sais jamais
si jamais tous ces bourses à la même
chose non mais c'est l'exemple que nous
donne parce que c'est du vécu donc bon
du coup
les les élus et leur vocation bien
évidemment à soutenir valérie pécresse
et c'est comme ça que ça va se passer
pour les exceptionnels et l'instant
dizaines de milliers d'élus que l'on a
goûté on verra ce moment là lorsque le
cas sera le cas sera posée on n'ira pas
forcément de sanctions
je pense que ça n'est f1 je suis pas
dans le domaine de la sanction entente
elle simplement un élu keller et doit
assumer ses responsabilités il est l air
il est dans une famille politique
désigner un candidat il soutient set
cornet vous avez grandi dans un souffle
sauf que valérie pécresse elle dit si un
élu et l'air par n eric zemmour il sera
sanctionné même exclure non non non
d'abord le président des républicains
vous l'avez votre ado table et sur ce
sujet il n'y a pas de la vocation et les
évidentes les candides les élus aient
l'air soutiennent valérie pécresse s'il
y a un cas où deux particuliers ou trois
ans les réglera voilà et on verra la
manière dont les choses se sont faites
mais mais c'est de cet ordre là et bien
évidemment qu'en revanche
quelqu'un qui est qui ferait campagne
contre valérie pécresse pas bien
évidemment n'a plus rien à faire chez
les républicains il faut laisser venir
les choses christian jacob président du
parti des républicains invité de france
info jusqu'à 9 heures le fil info à 8h41
avec diane farr shit
dans la crise du crédit anne-emmanuelle
mâcon se rendra en russie l'inde y ait
en ukraine mardi le chef de l'état qui
s'est entretenu avec ses homologues
russe et ukrainien hier soir pour tenter
d'apaiser les tensions alors que
washington accusé moscou de vouloir
filmer une fausse attaque de kiev afin
d'avoir un prétexte pour envahir
l'ukraine sur france info la fcpe dit
envisager très sérieusement d'aller en
justice pour faire valoir les droits des
élèves à avoir un professeur devant eux
en classe avec la crise sanitaire la
fédération de parents d'élèves dénoncent
plus de 40 mille heures de cours perdues
à cause du non remplacement des
enseignants un chiffre issu de son
recensement participatif en ligne pour
marine le pen il ya chez eric zemmour
toute une série de chapelles venue du
est venu puis reparti du front national
la candidate du rassemblement national
évoque même dans le figaro la présence
de quelques nazis dans les rangs à
d'eric zemmour quelles sont les chances
de médaille pour les athlètes français à
pékin on attend beaucoup notamment du
biathlon ces jeux d'hiver et commence
cet après midi à 13h heure française
début de la cérémonie d'ouverture qui
sera à suivre sur france info
france info
le 8 30 france info samia ben radhia
mauvaise note toujours et christian
jacob le président du parti les
républicains le syndicat de police
alliance a fait passer un grand oral au
candidat à la présidentielle cette
semaine on a vu beaucoup de points
communs entre valérie pécresse marine le
pen et eric zemmour est ce que vous
pouvez nous dire sur le sujet de la
sécurité quelle est leur principale
différence je ne connais pas les les les
positions d'eric zemmour et de marine le
pen il y a aujourd'hui un vrai défaut
d'autorité et elle valérie pécresse a à
la fois lire la personnalité pour
incarner cette autorité elle l'a montré
en dirigeant comme elle elle le fait
depuis six ans la une grande région la
région ile de france
ce déficit d'autorité il est à la fois
liée à des mesures qui aujourd'hui s'en
sont nécessaires dans la loi mais c'est
aussi la capacité de l'incarner lorsque
le le président de la république
lorsque vous souvenez de l'aéroport de
notre dame des landes
est envahi par des voyous et des
casseurs qui saccagent le centre-ville
qui brûlent des voitures de gendarmes
l'autorité n'est pas incarnée par le
président de la république lorsque l'on
à un ministre de l'intérieur du
gouvernement de monsieur mâcon qui dit
qu'il est prêt à poser un genou à terre
devant les policiers il
est l'autorité n'est pas n'est pas
incarné lorsque les lorsque les peines
lorsque les rythmes enfin aux états unis
l'âge précise louis de la sorte il est
vrai qu'elle est elle le sujet pense qu
on a en france des forces de sécurité
extrêmement respectueuse lorsqu'il y à
des dérapages et sont sanctionnés sont
sanctionnés durement ensuite on a un
vrai problème sur la justice sur le les
peines qui ne sont pas exécutées sur les
peines plancher qui ont été supprimées
par françois hollande et que le
président de la répu l'actuel
gouvernement n'a pas remis en place
disons que on ne peut pas s'en prendre
aux forces de police et donc il ya la
nécessité de remettre des peines
planchers pour tout ceux qui agressent
les forces de police pour les
récidivistes pour tous ces individus
dont la sanction ne tombe jamais et
prononcé mais ne tombent ne tombe jamais
donc il ya vraiment
comment avec marine le pen et avec ceux
qui considèrent que c'est trop laxiste
mais je ne connais pas leurs
propositions
nous nous avons c'est à dire un avantage
sur ce sujet c'est que nos propositions
elles sont écrites ce sont des
propositions de loi on les sort pas par
un claquement de doigts ce sont des
propositions depuis sept ou huit ans il
ya des propositions de loi qui ont été
déposées à l'assemblée nationale au
sénat par les groupes parlementaires
aient l'air donc sûr nous sommes sur des
choses assumer et pas sur des effets de
manche de campagne valérie pécresse dit
qu'elle veut réformer la légitime
défense dans quel cadre exactement sur
la proportionnalité qu'il peut y avoir à
la défense lorsque vous êtes agressé
dire de laisser de s'appuyer en fait sur
le le droit suisse sur ce sujet qui
permet effectivement aux juges de
pouvoir interpréter la l'acte de défense
lorsque votre vie est mise en cause par
un individu qui pénètre chez vous qui
sagres et qui vous agressent et bien que
l'on puisse évaluer avec plus de
souplesse qu'on me le fais aujourd'hui
la réaction que l'on peut avoir pour
défendre sa vie donc ça s'appliquerait à
tous les citoyens pas uniquement forces
de l'ordre et ça passe devant bien
entendu mais c'est la justice qui
redessine ça passe devant le juge on est
très loin de là la procédure de proposer
par exemple pour ses excuses à voir des
petits où on arrive à un dérapage ou ça
peut devenir a permis de tuer quoi c'est
à dire qu'ils puissent qui supprime
complètement la référence à la
proportionnalité nous on veut passer
devant le juge dans ses derniers
discours valérie pécresse utilise une
expression qu'elle n'avait pas utilisé
jusqu'à présent et qu'on entendait dans
des discours d'eric zemmour elle dit je
la cite il faut éradiquer les zones de
non france qu'est ce que c'est qu'une
zone de non france passe est une zone on
ne respecte pas les règles de la
république est d'ailleurs valérie
pécresse s'était opposée vous souvenez
lorsque il ya vu des dérapages sur des
des prières de rue avec des actes
violents valérie pécresse qui était allé
avait pris ses responsabilités dans ce
cadre la présidente de la la région ile
de france et on ne peut pas tolérer que
des des zones des zones des quartiers
les règles de la république ne soit pas
respectée c'est généralement une grosse
pression zone de non-droit non franck
est ce que ça veut dire qu'elle sait
l'étranger qui a pris le pouvoir c'est
parfois des communautés effectivement
étrangères qu'on peut le pouvoir mais
les règles les règles une lotion
diverses où on l'avait vu à auxerre avec
vous souvenez pas auxerre pardon
tradition indigents
des gens du voyage voilà vous avez
raison qu'ils avaient pris les armes
dans la rue il en france on peut avoir
oui non mais on a eu des cas en
l'occurrence il n'y avait pas eu
que les gens du voyage il y avait eu
aussi j'ai peur de me tromper de
nationalité kosovare est il a dédié ce
corps me noté étrangères qui avait pris
qu'ils aient pris les armes donc ces
zones de non france sont des endroits où
des communautés
prend le pouvoir mais où les règles de
la république ne sont aps le respect que
je vous dis que là c'est quoi c'est du
grand remplacement light en fait non non
je reprends absolument pas ce terme cas
pas beaucoup de sens c'est simplement la
france la nation est une et indivisible
elle ne peut pas être l'addition de
communautés où chacun préserve son pré
carré c'était le discours d' emmanuel
macron là aussi du doudou violement
lorsque emmanuel macron vous souvenez de
son discours à marseille où il dit je
vois ici des comoriens je vois ici fin
ici de différentes nationalités non
monsieur le président de la république
voyez si les français il ya une
communauté à les françaises c'est pas
une addition de communautés différentes
la france christian jacob pourquoi
est-ce que valérie pécresse ne veut pas
utiliser le terme de violences
policières mais parce qu'il n'y a pas de
violences policières en france moi je me
suis déjà exprimé je n'accepte pas ce
propos caisse violences policières
nous avons il ya un état de droit en
france nous avons une police et une
gendarmerie des forces de sécurité qui
sont extrêmement respectueuse du droit
lorsqu'ils font ils utilisent la
répression et la force c'est parce que
il y a nécessité d'utiliser la force et
quand il est anormal
pénalité dans les dents et la
proportionnalité parfaitement respecte
en tous les cas si dans tous les cas
lorsqu'il ya un dérapage il est condamné
condamner fermement et dans ce cas là
que les policiers aient passé qu'elle
condamne comment vous appelez ça eh bien
c'est quelqu'un qui n'a pas respecté les
règles mais mais mais ce terme de
violence policière n'a aucun sens il est
ridicule de l'utiliser en france
christian jacob le premier ministre jean
castex a annoncé un débat au parlement
sur l'engagement de la france au mali on
rappelle que l'ambassadeur français a
été expulsé en début de semaine par
l'armée malienne au pouvoir qui s'est
donc alliée avec la milice russo wagner
est ce que c'est un échec pour la mer
pour l'armée française
c'est là aussi un échec supplémentaire
des manuels macron sur la scène
internationale lorsqu en 2013 le
président traoré demande à la france de
d'intervenir on le fait les premières
opérations pour éviter qu'il y ait
reconstitution d'un dèche
au sahel
donc ces opérations continues on voit
bien que aujourd'hui il y a il s'agit
pas de capituler mais il s'agit de se
faire respecter si le gouvernement
malien ne veut plus de nous ne veut plus
de la france la question effectivement
du retrait se pose elle se pose au mali
et se pose pas au sahel parce que le
risque de jean claude calisesi vallée
existe est élu c'est valérie qui lui
reste il répondra bien évidemment mais
je dis que cette question notre est
posée la france ne peut pas être humilié
quitter le championnat mais pas quitter
le sahel dans cinq ans a quitté le saleh
le sahel parce que le risque de
reconstitution de 2 atl2 dèche il existe
donc pas la zone totalement non non il
ya la nécessité en revanche je pense que
là aussi et encore une fois lille jédir
l'impuissance du président de la
république française de ne pas avoir eu
la capacité aussi de mobiliser nos nos
pays allié de l'union européenne
il ya un moment il faut aussi à ce mot a
dit oui non mais d'accord mais faut
aussi que nos partenaires européens
considèrent que la france n'a pas à elle
seule la capacité de protéger toute
l'union le problème du mali de l'armée
malienne qui est au pouvoir parce
qu'elle s'allie à une mini non mais bien
entendu mais c'est pas si on a une
excuse jatte qui aujourd'hui refusent
non mais tout à fait mais je dis que se
pose comme le en matière de défense et
de protection contre les actes de
terrorisme la question que nos
partenaires européens devraient
s'engager davantage et ça ça nécessite
une négociation au sein de l'union
européenne
par ailleurs aujourd'hui on a un
gouvernement malien a dirigé par une
junte militaire qui met des bâtons dans
les roues aux soldats français pour
intervenir que comme et comme il se doit
avec effectivement
wagner les commandos wagner qui stocke
qu'ils sont sur place et dont on n'a pas
vocation à être humilié
8h51 on vous retrouve dans un instant
christian jacob le temps du fil info
avec bien de faire pschitt
comment décarbonés l'industrie française
d'ici 2030 un plan de 6 milliards
d'euros sera présentée tout à l'heure
par le premier ministre jean castex
depuis dunkerque d'un quart pour
arcelormittal va fermer deux trois de
ses hauts fourneaux pour construire de
nouvelles aciéries électriques à un
projet qui permettra de maintenir
l'emploi sur arcelormittal une hausse de
28% en 2022 pour le budget alloué à la
prise en charge des auteurs de violences
conjugales annonce de la ministre
chargée de l'égalité entre les femmes et
des hommes elisabeth moreno sur france
bleu isère ce budget sera donc portée à
plus de 6 millions d'euros c'est au
parquet d'evreux d'organiser dans les
prochains jours l'incarcération des
époux balkany la justice a confirmé la
révocation de leur placement sous
bracelet électronique en cause trop de
manquements une décision totalement
injuste selon l'ancien maire de
levallois condamné pour fraude fiscale
après plusieurs échanges téléphoniques
c'est en personne qu emmanuel macron
s'entretiendra avec vladimir poutine il
se rendra en russie lundi pour espérer
parvenir à une désescalade dans la crise
ukrainienne le créneau emmanuel macron
ce sera le lendemain là il rencontrera
le président volodymyr zelensky
[Musique]
france info
le 8 30 france info samia bras qui a
marqué aux veines pour la toute petite
précision passé au passage on parlait il
ya quelques minutes des violences comme
il ya quelques mois du côté de dijon
c'était la communauté tchétchène qui
était en cause à l'époque et pas les
kosovars comme jeudi par erreur pardon
salir christian jacob deux maisons à 2
millions d'euros chacune à la baule une
troisième maison à versailles au même
prix le patrimoine de votre candidat
temps valérie pécresse fait beaucoup
parler est ce que c'est un handicap
d'avoir une candidate qui a beaucoup
d'argent s'ils n'ont pas écouté
valérie pécresse était une transparence
totale comme doivent l'être tous les
tous les candidats
ella ella patrimoine et l'or n'a pas
sans s'en cacher elle ne met pas non
plus en exergue et on ne juge pas la
qualité d'un candidat cela moi je juge
valérie pécresse qui savait ce qu'elle
était capable de faire depuis six ans
dans la région ile de france où elle a
vraiment changer les choses que ce soit
en matière de transport sur les lycées
sur tous les champs de compétence sur la
capac les capacités qu'on était la
sienne les siennes a dirigé de grands
ministères qu'est ce que ça peut créer
un fond un fossé avec une bonne partie
des français qui peuvent être surpris de
voir un tel patrimoine mais tout d'abord
ce patrimoine ce n'est pas une surprise
parce qu'elle l'a toujours assumé très
clairement et ce rendement d'un
président de la république et je préfère
d'ailleurs avoir quelqu'un qui est
capable de cet constituée à perdre un
patrimoine plutôt que d'autres qui
flambent tout en allant me fait quand on
souvenez-vous de ministres qui nous
expliquait qu'avec leur paye deux
ministres il avait 150 euros 200 euros
sur un sur un pel ça c'est plus
inquiétant pour être capable de gérer
les affaires de la france valérie
pécresse a un patrimoine elle a aussi un
mari oui
le patron le patron de l'une des
principales branches du géant general
electric en france est ce que c'est un
éventuel conflit d'intérêts de diriger
une très grande entreprise qui pourra
dépendre des décisions
est élu est-ce qu'il devra quitter son
métier s'il a dû analyser tout est
absolument pas vous avez peut-être
vouloir aussi qu'on les choisisse son
mari tant qu on
allait tout ça tourne tout ça tourne au
ridicule pas de colère il intelligent
n'ont aucun à son mari exercent des
responsables et à des roulements de
carrière ont reproché à son mari d'avoir
un déroulement de carrière la question
parce que dans sa dernière déclaration
de patrimoine valérie pécresse explique
qu'elle possède des dizaines de milliers
d'actions de l'entreprise de son mari ce
qui est parfaitement légal mais ça veut
dire que en fonction des décisions qui
seraient prises sur le nucléaire sur
l'éolien sur les énergies renouvelables
ces actions elles peuvent monter ou
baisser exécutés et l'a toujours assumé
tous la dhr parfaite transparence mais
les biens présidentielle bien évidemment
mais a exercé des postes de
responsabilité importante
encore une fois je reviens sur la région
ile de france sur des postes
ministériels à la elle avait décidé de
bloquer un prix moindre le conflit
justement un gestionnaire pour pas
qu'ils aideraient la question leur
manière de la feb elle a toujours assumé
s'il ya quelqu'un qui a toujours été
très transparent et sans la moindre
ambiguïté sur ressemble son patrimoine
et sur dur le déroulement de carrière de
son mari c'est bien elle pourquoi c'est
toujours les femmes qui mettent leurs
métiers de côté
jamais les maris ah
oui enfin je vois pas le quai sturm à la
question la pose souvent quand c'est
dans l'autre sens oui mais parce que le
seul point candidat
christian jacob est-ce que vous avez des
nouvelles de nicolas sarkozy oui oui je
le vois très prochainement et pourquoi
il ne donne plus transmettrait vos
amitiés c'était
pour elle ne s'exprime pas sur la
présidentielle pourquoi il ne donne
toujours pas de consigne de vote en
faveur de valérie pécresse à moins de 70
jours du premier tour d'abord parce que
nicolas sarkozy n'est plus dans l'action
politique active et l'épée en
responsabilité et depuis de nombreuses
années maintenant en revanche bien
évidemment comme il l'a toujours dit il
y à un moment où s'exprimera il vous
tarde qu'il le fasse non non non non
parce que c'est le moment lui le
décidera il n'est pas dirigeants
politiques il s'est retiré il y reste
dans l'effort cosy à droite ça compte
mais mais mais mais tout ça ne m'a pas
échappé mais je vous dis qu'il le fera
le moment venu vous en avez la certitude
qui votera pour valérie pécresse il
voulut dur non mais vous vous entendez
bien évidemment mais l'intérêt ce sera
c'est lui qui s'exprime dans le
quinquennat il lui arrive et d'afficher
des signes de projet
justement qu'il
appelle inquiétudes de notre côté en
tout cas emmanuel bach points qui a déjà
les 500 signatures alors qu'il n'est pas
encore candidat est ce que ça vous met
déjà la pression
c'est pas une question de mettre la
pression mais je trouve que cette
situation est totalement inacceptable et
choquant on a un président de la
république qui se sert des deniers
publics pour faire sa campagne c'est à
dire que là on est clairement sur du
détournement de fonds publics il utilise
des fonds publics aujourd'hui les clés
sa campagne pour faire sa campagne
comment ça s'appelle lorsqu'un président
de la république utilise les moyens de
la république
non pas pour exercer ses responsabilités
mais en réalité pour faire campagne et
la démonstration vous avez des gens qui
parraine quelqu'un qui n'est pas
candidat le même s'ils avaient été faits
nicolas sarkozy oui et d'ailleurs la
commission des comptes de campagne
l'avait obligé à réintégrer un symptôme
de frais moi j'écris à l'école au
président de la commission des comptes
de campagne aucune réponse rien mais il
ya quand même un vrai sujet sur
l'utilisation outrancière des
financements publics du président de la
république pour des moyens personnels
pour ses moyens de campagne qu'il assume
de dire qu'il est candidat et à partir
de là de séparer clairement les choses
mais là on entretient un flou permanent
kitty qui est choquant le dire
ça n'est pas acceptable que le président
de la république se conduisent de cette
manière et tous les moyens soient mises
soit mise à disposition li siens et ceux
de ses conseillers puisque on voit bien
que les conseillers maintenant commence
à passer du temps soit disant dans une
benne arrière bureau je sais pas trop où
exactement
pour préparer la campagne mais non mais
travail à l'elysée mais en même temps
sur leur temps libre ils vont travailler
sur autre chose qu'on arrête de se fiche
du monde que le président de la
république dise clairement je suis
candidat et à partir de là il y a des
moyens que j'utilise pour ma campagne
électorale et des moyens qui sont
utilisés pour présider la france or
aujourd'hui c'est la confusion c'est des
moyens publics qui sont utilisés à des
fins personnelles et politicienne du
président christian jacob président du
parti les républicains étaient ce matin
et je l'en remercie l'invité de france
info bonne journée à vous merci
[Musique]
mathilde thomas fondatrice de caudalie
nous parle de son innovation anti-âge
premiers crus la crème après dix ans de
recherche nous avons breveté avec
l'université de médecine de harvard une
nouvelle technologie inspirée de la
science de l'épigénétique résultats 1er
cru la crème corrige les huit marqueurs
de l'âge rides et ridules tâche et éclat
élasticité